SPEAKER 1: Thank you, everyone,
for this special edition
of talks at Google as a fireside
chat with Mr. Nadeem Hussain.
Mr. Nadeem Hussain is one of
Asia's leading social impact
entrepreneurs, tech investors,
and financial inclusion
pioneers.
He is the founder of Telenor
Microfinance Bank, formally,
Tameer Microfinance--
recognized by the
World Bank as one
of the largest and most socially
impactful banks in the field
globally.
EasyPaisa offering from the bank
has revolutionized Pakistan's
mobile financial
services industry.
His latest venture,
Planet N Group
is Pakistan's foremost
technology growth capital
and incubator platform,
focusing on financial inclusion
and facilitation of
entrepreneurship in Pakistan
through technology.
And he has added 24
companies to his portfolio
across e-commerce,
financial technology,
educational technology,
mobile television, retail,
and renewable energy.
Let's welcome our speaker.
[APPLAUSE]
Mr. Nadeem, you had--
NADEEM HUSSAIN: You
can call me Nadeem.
SPEAKER 1: Nadeem, you
had an unusual beginning
after spending nearly
30 years in banking.
You came back to Pakistan
to start a new venture
at the age of 49?
NADEEM HUSSAIN: Yep.
SPEAKER 1: What
was easy and what
was hard to start
something new at that age?
And how did you decide to
start a microfinance bank
back in Pakistan after having
lived in different countries?
NADEEM HUSSAIN: So I spent
about 27 years with Citigroup
in about eight
different countries.
And my last assignment
was actually
out of the buyable that
was responsible for Iraq
during the sovereign
debt restructuring.
So of that 27 years,
I spent half my time
in investment consumer
marketing and half my time
in risk management.
I was 49 years old, and I
figured of that 27 years,
I only spent 5 years in
Pakistan launching the consumer
bank in Pakistan.
Otherwise, I'd been
outside Pakistan.
And I felt it was time for me
to go back and do something
in Pakistan.
Pakistan had been kind to me.
I'd got where I had because
of my education in Pakistan
and subsequently in the US.
But this talk of saying that
I've done enough at Citi--
You know, I had become
relatively senior in Citibank,
making decent
money, but I wanted
to go back and create
something in Pakistan,
and I hoped I would be
able to change an industry.
It was very ambitious
for a person who had only
worked five years in Pakistan
and had actually never done
microfinance before.
And the reason I wanted to
do microfinance were twofold.
One was simply capital.
If I wanted to own
a bank in Pakistan,
a commercial bank capital
requirement was $100 million
and a microfinance capital
requirement was $10 million.
So you can see that decision
was an easy decision
to get into as far as capital
requirement was concerned.
But there's huge financial
exclusion in Pakistan.
Of a country right now
of 200 million people,
less than 6.7 million people
have access to formal credit.
So my view was that if we could
create a microfinance bank,
which could actually
institutionalize this process,
you know, create a bank which
was run by professionals
as opposed to necessary.
But it's not that the
other institutions are not
run by professionals.
But people who had capital
market experience, people
who had consumer
experience, people
who had global
experience-- you would have
to learn microfinance
because all
my knowledge of microfinance
was a book written by Dr. Yunus.
So I hadn't done
microfinance before,
so that was a challenge.
But I thought that we would be
able to create a world class
institution using the
27 years of knowledge I
had at Citi and the
capital I'd built up
at Citi through options.
And the funny part is that
when I exited Citibank,
Citibank stock was $35.
You know, it came down to
close to $2 afterwards,
so that wasn't--
thinking on my
part, it was luck.
But right now I was reading
the Citibank stock--
Citicorp stock is
back to 2009 years.
It was a big
decision in the sense
that I'd spent 27 years
working for one company,
getting a salary, in a very
comfortable environment.
You know, when you're
getting a check every month,
you're getting a nice
bonus every year,
you get transported
to a new country
and the company
takes care of you.
It's a nice life.
And it's not boring
because you're
moving from country to
country, so it's a new market.
So you're always getting
a different experience.
When I was growing up, like
most Pakistanis at that stage,
my ambition was to become
the head of a multinational
in Pakistan, because, you
know, it's a great job.
You get a lot of perks.
Make a million bucks,
and I'd be done.
That was my initial
ambition, and you know,
I'd be a happy camper.
I never, at that stage,
thought I'd work for myself
or create a company for myself,
because that whole mindset
at that time was to go find
a multinational to work
for, and get promoted,
and become a country
head or maybe a regional head.
So the first transition
was that I would
be creating my own company.
And my family comes from the
middle class in Pakistan.
My father used to be
in the Pakistan Navy
and then got into the
automotive industry.
My mother was a high
school principal.
There was no examples of any
entrepreneurship in my family,
so I was the first
person to actually move
from a salaried job into an
entrepreneurship kind of thing.
So that was a first
decision, moving away
from the safety net of a
nice tax free job in Dubai,
coming back to
Pakistan, and you know,
putting my own capital at risk.
So out of the $10 million,
I put in $6 million.
IFC put in a million
dollars, and there
were two local investors
who put in $3 million
to get to the $10 million.
The second thing was I had
never worked in Pakistan
beyond five years.
And actually I was a Pakistani.
I used to go back
every year to Pakistan.
Working in Pakistan,
especially in the microfinance
environment, would
be very different,
so that was another challenge
that I knew I would experience.
But I'm an impulsive
kind of person.
So once the bug bit me that
I was going to go back,
I actually didn't
wait for my bonus--
which that year, incidentally,
would have been half a million
bucks, because we just
finished the sovereign debt
restructuring of Pakistan.
And Citibank made close to
$120 million on that deal.
It was a massive deal.
So I was country head,
Iraq, but I couldn't wait.
So I just gave in my
resignation saying
I'm going go back to Pakistan.
And my boss said, hold on.
I was four months away.
I said, no, I can't wait.
I've got to go back.
And I just went back
and started Tameer Bank.
SPEAKER 1: Micro
enterprises tend
to estimate that demand-side
interest rates are typically
high for micro loans.
And recent randomized controlled
trials show that direct cash
transfers-- that is, cash
without any strings attached--
has more impact on
poverty and livelihoods.
So how does Telenor Bank
ensure that micro loans are
impactful in upward mobility
and breaking out of the poverty
cycle for the communities?
NADEEM HUSSAIN: I
thought this was
going to be an easy interview.
[LAUGHTER]
So there are two
schools of thought,
and both come up with
scientific evidence.
One says, in a controlled
group environment,
when you do microfinance
lending, over a period of time,
you actually show improvement.
And it was out of an equal
group of people who actually
demonstrate that,
no, you can't isolate
that improvement whether it's
a floor that's been converted
from mud to wood, or a
bathroom had been put in,
or kids are going to school,
or there's less people getting
sick because of the incremental
income that you have--
is not necessarily due
to the intervention
of the microfinance
bank, but there
could be other sources
of income coming in.
And because money's
fungible, you
can't necessarily isolate
the impact microfinance
lending has had.
So both exist, and both are done
by very prominent people who've
done A/B testing
and demonstrated
that they are right.
In my 11 years, my sense was
that I met enough customers
that we changed their lives.
The intervention we had done had
made them actually better off
than they were before.
The big risk in microfinance
is that overindebtedness.
You get a customer to
actually take more money
than he or she can repay,
and that's when they default.
Otherwise, typically, the rates
of default in microfinance,
if you got the right undwriting,
are typically under 1%.
The big challenge
in microfinance
is not that your
customer is going
to default because they
haven't given you collateral.
It's your business model.
How do you take care of
the long tail customer?
Your business model
takes into account
that you're going to sell, as
opposed to a bag of teabags,
one [INAUDIBLE] at a time.
So you have to build
a business model that
incorporates that you're selling
one [INAUDIBLE] at a time.
And unless you can
do that-- and that's
why large commercial banks are
not successful in microfinance,
because their business
model is very different.
It's, you know, $100
million, or $10 million,
or a couple hundred thousand
dollars of loan at a time.
But microfinance is
one loan acquired
at a time for an average
of maybe $350 or $300,
where the customer has
no finances, no credit
report of any kind,
and you're actually
estimating their ability
to repay the debt
service by human intervention.
And that's the reason that,
typically, microfinance rates
are high.
It's not because microfinance
banks make a lot of money.
So if you look at, globally,
what kind of money microfinance
banks make or microfinance
institutions make,
it's not a very high number.
You'll you'll find
a microfinance bank
making $100 million or
$50 million of income.
It's rare, I would
say, at current,
like 10 banks,
globally, would do that.
The reason the rates
are high is the cost
of customer acquisition and
the cost of underwriting.
So if you look at
interest rate--
let's say the
interest rate's 30%.
And you said, well, you
know, you're a poor guy,
and you're lending at 30%.
That's not fair.
I mean, you're
gouging a customer
who's already very poor.
So what service
are you providing?
You're just maximizing
your own returns.
But if you break and
peel that onion of 30%,
you find out that out of
that 30%, typically 15%
is cost of administration.
Why?
Because very few
microfinance banks
use scorecards for the
moment, so everything
is human intervention.
Tameer Bank had 2,000 people
by the time I was exiting.
Because you need to go
and see the customer.
You need to figure out, are they
able to repay your debt or not?
So you have to go
a couple of times
to figure out what their
repayment ability is.
Because typically, in developing
countries at that level,
corruption is high because
these people are not
used to getting anything
done without paying money.
So if they need a passport,
they need a CNIC card,
which is like an
identity card, they're
always needing some kind of
money [INAUDIBLE] in between.
So typically they're
immediately offering money
to your relationship
manager, and that's
something you know
you want to avoid
because you want to have a
culture of where money is being
taken.
So you have a separate
person waiting
on a verification process.
When they go and recheck that
the customer's estimation
of what you're estimating
the repayment is correct.
Then you have to
talk to the neighbor
to see if this person
has been living
in his house for a long time.
Then you go to his place of work
and talk to his neighbor again.
So it's a very laborious,
people-intensive process.
And commercial banks cost
about-- administration
is typically around 2%, 3%.
A microfinance bank is 15%.
Then you have cost of .
Funds typically commercial
banks have low cost of funds
because they have checking
accounts or they have savings
accounts.
Typically, microfinance banks
don't have checking accounts.
They can't.
Tameer Bank had one, but
most microfinance banks
are dependent on going
to the independent market
to raise money.
Because the customer's view
is, if I have to borrow money,
I'll borrow from a microfinance,
but if I have to deposit money,
I'll go to a commercial bank
because that money's safe.
So if you're willing
to lend to me,
you can't be all that, you know,
strong as far as your capital
adequacy is concerned.
So it takes time for
microfinance banks
to reduce the cost of funds.
Typically, you're borrowing
300 basis points over the money
market rate.
So let's say the money market
rate in Pakistan is 6%.
Typically, microfinance
will borrow at 9% to 10%.
So 15% plus 10%, you're at 25%.
Let's say default is
1%, so you're at 26%.
If your margin of 1%
or 2%, you're at 28%.
So the rates are
high, but that's
the reason the rates are high.
If microfinance banks start
investing in technology,
you can bring that
administration count down.
If every time you're improving
secondary using scorecards
or artificial intelligence
to create algorithms which
can forecast what your
default rate is going to be,
you can bring some of that
administration cost down.
If you create checking account
or mobile account programs,
you can bring your
cost of funding down.
So in Tameer, my ambition
was to bring out--
our ending rate was 28%,
so bring it down to 15%.
And credit card rates in
Pakistan are 30%, 32%.
So, you know, hopefully
the new management
is looking towards that.
But that's the reason.
Microfinance rates
range from 30% to 40%,
but they don't make that much
money just because of the way
this whole business model is.
SPEAKER 1: So Telenor Bank
has created and instituted
a successful mobile payment
system called EasyPaisa,
and many have tried to
introduce mobile money in Asia,
but there have been
very few successes.
How did Tameer go about
creating a new infrastructure
and network to
enable mobile money?
What are the
challenges you faced,
and how did you overcome them?
NADEEM HUSSAIN: The
biggest challenge
in creating a
mobile distribution
network is behavioral change.
And you've got to
realize that the poor are
willing to pay for services.
They don't want charity.
And their view of value for
money is much, much more acute
than yours and
mine, so you know,
we spend some extra money.
But they have a finite
budget, and they
have to work within that.
And they are willing to pay
for value if you create value.
They are never going to
pay for more than that.
But there's a behavior
change requirement.
So when we looked at
Pakistan, and we said,
listen, this financial
exclusion that we
have is not limited to credit.
It's also limited to savings.
Since 1947 in Pakistan,
it was created--
it's going to be 70
years this month--
the entire commercial
banking industry
has only opened close to
32 million bank accounts.
And if I take unique
bank accounts,
you're probably talking
about 15 million.
And the savings [INAUDIBLE]
in Pakistan is under 6%.
So we said there ought to be a
solution for savings as well.
And savings generation
get generated
when you start payments.
So how do we create
a payments culture?
Pakistan is a cash society.
And there's about
3.3 million rupees
of money floating in the system
because everybody pays cash.
In a country of
200 million people,
unfortunately,
registered taxpayers
are about 1.2 million.
The bulk of the taxes are
collected in a indirect basis.
So people don't
have bank accounts.
They want to keep money.
But they use money
all the time-- cash--
and cash is expensive.
You know, it depreciates in
terms of its physical form.
You need to carry it.
It can get stolen.
So if you can do digital
payments, in many ways,
you're better off.
So we said, OK, we want to get
into the branchless banking
business.
And again, the idea of EasyPaisa
didn't just come to me.
And I went to Kenya
to look at M-Pesa.
I went to Philippines
to look at GCash.
And I looked at
various applications,
and obviously, Telenor was
a partner at that time,
so they had some
insights as well.
And we said the
easiest way to get
people to start using
branchless banking as payment
of utility bills.
Now you guys typically pay
through your phone maybe.
But in Pakistan, every
month other than the telco
payments, 30 million
utility bills
are created for
power, gas, water.
And people typically
go to a bank,
get in line during
banking hours,
give up their work time
to make that payment.
And banks hate these
people because they
congest the lobbies.
So can you imagine,
they're not bank customers.
They're just coming
to pay utility bills,
and they're standing
at the teller
while the bank
customer's on the side.
So the bank makes it as
difficult as possible
for these guys to pay, but
that was the only venue.
And we said OK, if we can
create a mechanism where we just
start accepting utility bills
and make it easier compared
to what they're
doing right now, we
can start a behavioral change.
12,700 banks in
Pakistan, 9,000 ATMs
where people never use
ATMs for repayment of bills
although you can.
95% of use is just
for cash withdrawals.
That's a typical psyche.
You can even make an
inter-bank payment through ATM,
but people don't.
They just use it
for cash withdrawal.
That's the psyche globally.
So we said, Pakistan
has now, let's say,
90 million unique SIMs--
people with 420 million
SIM cards outstanding.
And 99% of those are pre-paid.
So it's not like post-paid
accounts over here.
Most people actually buy
scratchcards or do a top up
very frequently in
the month whenever
they run out of SIM balance.
In order to accommodate that,
the telcos had to set up
a vast [? agent ?] network
where people could go and buy
SIM cards.
Just like India,
just like Bangladesh,
and most developing countries.
So the telcos had set up
an [? agent ?] network,
multiple of what the
bank branch network was.
So the vision was if you
can change that [? agent ?]
network into providing basic
banking service like opening
an account, closing an
account, making a utility bill,
making a transfer,
then you would actually
create an alternative network--
which would be far more
convenient for the target
market we were looking at
it, because this network
is in the neighborhood.
It's open seven days a week.
It's open probably
14 hours a day.
The owner doesn't
go to play golf.
So it's something
that's service-oriented
because these agents are selling
a whole bunch of other stuff
other than just airtime.
So we basically started
onboarding telco agents
for accepting utility
bill payments.
Now that was a
behavioral change.
When these customers go to a
bank, they see a bank brand.
They see the board of the bank.
And they're comfortable that
my payment, when I make it,
is going to go through
the utility company,
and my power won't be cut off.
So we are telling
them, hey, guys,
why don't you go to the small
shop, the mom-and-pop store
in your neighborhood
and pay your utility
bill, and you're going to be OK?
And the guy says hell no.
If I can't make this payment,
and this guy shuts down
tomorrow, and my power gets
cut off, where's my address?
Who do I go to?
So we tried to overcome
that by issuing
a receipt by Telenor Bank.
So we said, listen, Telenor
Bank is a central bank
regulated entity.
If your power gets cut
off, you can take the bank,
go to the central bank,
and the central bank
will make you whole.
And the second policy we had
was because the average payment
was very small.
The average utility
payment for the common man
was under 2,000 rupees.
So our policy was never
dispute, just make that payment,
so that power
never gets cut off.
Even if you think the
customer is in the wrong,
just make that payment.
Get that confidence level up
so this behavioral change takes
place, so people start
paying the utility bills
at the local mom-and-pop
store as opposed to a bank.
And that was the behavioral
change we wanted.
We ran a lot of campaigns.
We tried brand
ambassadors standing
at these mom-and-pop stores,
saying pay your utility bill.
It's interesting.
Here's a receipt.
And our own policy was
no dispute, just pay.
And the time I left,
Tameer bank was doing 10%
of the $30 million bills paid.
So $3 million bills were
being paid through us.
And that customer saw this
confidence of actually going
to a mom-and-pop store and doing
a banking transaction started.
So that was the initial step.
The second step we said-- and
I know if you're in a startup,
you make great plans.
And when you go to the
ground, you sometimes
find out that those plans are in
the [? basement ?] of a basket
because you called it
wrong, but you have
to figure out a way to pivot.
So we thought our
biggest product was going
to be international remittance.
Pakistan gets $17 billion a
year from workers in the Middle
East, in the UK, and in the US.
And we said, you
know, bank branches,
12,700 close on a Sunday,
half day on Saturday,
closed long period on
Friday for prayers.
We would be able to use
our agents across Pakistan,
60,000 agents, and be able
to do this payment out.
And therefore the
large payment providers
would flock to come
to us because we would
have such great distribution.
Well, the only thing
we miscalculated
was the average remittance
size is $40,000-- sorry,
40,000 rupees.
And the small agent
doesn't have liquidity
to pay out five of
these payments in a day.
And all you need is--
if Pakistanis go to ATM
and it's not working,
it's oh, no problem.
But if you go to withdraw
cash from a [INAUDIBLE]
banking agent, and
there's no cash,
they say, oh, these
guys are frauds.
And that whole confidence
level you've built up changes.
So our international
remittance product failed.
But in that whole
learning process,
we understood that
there's a huge component
of domestic remittance.
$15 billion are paid
domestically in Pakistan.
And the way the
money's transferred
is something called
hawala hundi, which
is informal payments
through money agents,
or through the post office, or
people going to your hometown
and you just give them the cash.
So they give it to
your family back home.
And we said, let's try
domestic remittance.
And domestic remittance
was a phenomenal success.
And as I said, in
our regional plan,
there was no domestic
remittance as a product.
But that's when you
start pivoting, too--
when your original plan fails.
And that's what actually was
the biggest behavioral change
in the industry we created--
that instead of going
to informal channels,
you could go to an
EasyPaisa agent and say,
I want to transfer money.
And he would say, who do
you want to transfer to?
And in Pakistan there's
a universal identifier
called a computerized
national identity card.
So it's a 16 digit
number everybody has.
You just can't live
without, or you wouldn't
be able to do anything.
So if I was transferring
money to you,
I would show them my CNIC card.
I would give them
your CNIC card number.
If you had a cell phone, I'll
give you a cell phone number.
I'd get my cell phone number.
And then the agent would
hand over his feature phone,
because remember, you're
working on SMS at that time.
Smartphones hadn't come in.
And he would ask you to put in
a PIN number, six digit number.
Incidentally, 90% of those
PIN numbers were 123456.
But at Tameer, we
overcame that, OK?
[LAUGHTER]
And within three
minutes, that money
was available to 60,000 agents.
And the beneficiary
would go to the agent
and see if I had
the money come in.
He would say, OK,
show me your CNIC,
and they would
physically show the CNIC.
He'd say, OK.
The agent would give him the
phone and say put in your PIN--
miraculously, 123456
would be done,
and the money
would be withdrawn.
It was a huge
change from waiting
for the post office
or informal services,
and it was phenomenally
successful.
So we got to the second stage
of what was getting people now
to get to a comfort level
after utility bills,
to start making
domestic remittances.
The problem was that
we went to the agent.
The agent said, I'm
not going to do this.
You know, I make a 100%
margin on the things I sell.
This thing takes time.
You want me to add at
least 40 characters
by the time I'm done
with the transfer.
So I'm going to add the
CNIC number from myself,
CNIC number for you.
With just 16, there's 32 digits.
I'm going to add a 16 digit pin.
38 digits, it's
going to take time.
So they extracted the
pound of flesh then.
For every dollar we
made, they took $0.70.
That's the price we paid
for getting the agent
network to absorb or
except branchless banking.
With me, $0.30 were left, which
we split between the telco
Telenor and Tameer Bank.
So we had to again look
at doing huge volumes
to be able to make money, but
the agents were very happy
because initially,
they were reluctant,
but then they
started signing up.
But the end state
was mobile wallets,
because we are still not
into branchless banking
because we want
physical interaction.
You have to go to an agent.
It's like when I see an
ad in the paper, which
says XYZ Bank has
opened a digital branch.
You can walk into the
branch, and there's
no human intervention.
And I say to myself,
why in the hell would
I want to get in my car,
and travel for five miles,
and then go to the branch,
and say, wow, digital branch.
You know, the smartphone
is my digital branch.
I should be able to
transact anything
while sitting in
my bed watching,
you know, season three of "Game
of Thrones" and the latest
episode, and doing
my transactions.
So it's just mind boggling for
me, this digital branch concept
with no human intervention.
Maybe it's a busy street next
to your office, but why would
I even want to walk anywhere
to do my transactions?
So our next target was
creating mobile wallets.
That if you could create
mobile wallets instead of just
physical activity, and
if the customer was
able to populate the
mobile wallet, then,
you know, person to
person transactions,
utility bill payments, person
to business transactions,
G2P, government to person,
transactions would take place.
And there's 3.3 trillion
rupees floating,
and the system would start
coming into the banking system.
And we would have a
secondary revenue stream.
Maybe we would have some
float on these mobile wallets
versus the transaction fee.
So initially we
had a hurdle of how
to open these bank accounts,
because the central bank
required a physical face to face
to open a bank account for KYC
and anti-money laundering
purposes-- that
to know your customer,
you got to see them.
Now, that's a difficult call.
That means either the customer
would have to go to my branch
and my network of agents
would not be able to open,
or they would have to take a
photograph of the customer--
a photograph of the CNIC--
which meant that
the feature phone
wouldn't work because the
pixel quality was too poor.
And the agent would have to
have a smartphone, and who
would fund that smartphone?
So our advantage of having
a large network kind of
got underleveraged
as a consequence
of this requirement.
But sometimes things
happen in the industry
which don't happen
because of you,
but you get the benefit from.
So the Ministry of
Interior decided
that every person
with a cell phone
had to be biometrically
verified because there were
a lot of activities taking
place-- sometimes kidnappings,
sometimes terrorist activity
from cell phones they couldn't
identify.
So if I gave myself
my identity card
at the time I'm
making a transaction
to a branchless banking agent,
that branchless bank agent
could take my CNIC card and
have five more SIMs issued,
which I didn't know about.
So the Pakistan telcom authority
first came up with a way
that if you put in
your CNIC card number,
you find out how many SIMs
have been issued in your name.
And I did mine, I had 15 SIMs.
And I knew that only
three of those were mine,
and the rest were people using
my identity for creating a SIM
card account with telco.
They were paying them on
time, but it wasn't my SIM.
And if tomorrow
something happened,
the agencies or I
would be responsible.
So first this whole purge
took place of multiple SIMs
went away.
But they still said
it's not working,
so they said every SIM has
to be biometrically verified.
So if you hold the phone, you
would have to go into an agent
and be biometrically
verified, which
would be verified by the
National Identity Base we have
which is called NADRA, and then
your SIM would become active.
And if you wanted
a SIM immediately,
you couldn't get one.
You'd have to get
biometric verification.
You'd get an official
address, and it would
be delivered to your home.
That took away like 35 million
SIMs from the telephone market.
Immediately over a period of
time, the same took place.
But then we had a
very strong case.
And we went to the central
bank and said, hey,
this SIM is
biometrically verified
by the central database.
Why am I required
to see a customer?
Let's create bank accounts
in line with transactions
and know your customer risk.
So let's say we have something
called a level zero account.
And this level
zero account says,
you can do 50,000 rupees--
50,000 rupees is $50--
of transactions in a month.
That's good for
90% of Pakistanis,
given the per capita
income we have.
Central bank allowed
us and the industry
to do a remote account opening.
So all you have to do is send an
SMS to four of the banks which
are connected with telcos, and
you can open a mobile account.
The first thing that came about
was the one minute account,
which actually doesn't exist in
many countries, including here.
You have to physically go into
a bank to open an account.
In Pakistan, you can open a
level zero account remotely
under one minute.
So this hurdle of
opening a mobile account
went away with this
new regulation.
And right now there are
27 million mobile accounts
in Pakistan over a
three year period,
as opposed to the 32 million
bank accounts since 1947.
So branchless banking or
technology can actually
make a huge impact
when used properly,
and it can change
behavior of people.
So obviously, nothing is easy,
so we have 27 million or 23
million mobile accounts.
But the next question you would
ask me is, that's great, sir,
but how many are active?
Because opening an
account is easy,
because I run a sales
campaign where the agent gets
paid for every mobile account.
And he has his grandmother
and his dog opening an account
just because he wants
to get to that target
when we have got to pay him
for opening a mobile account.
But less than 25% are active.
And active is generously defined
as one transaction in 30 days.
That's the GSMA definition of
a mobile account being active.
So we have yet to
create the ecosystem
to have the customer leave
money in their mobile account,
so that this becomes
a source of revenue
for the branchless
banking players.
Because until you get to
a stage where I can-- so
I was given a number of--
getting to a tangent.
I was giving a speech about
what I call digital Pakistan.
And I said, three things need
to happen, and if we do that,
we'd get exponential growth.
The first one is the
one minute account,
and that's actually
taking place.
The second was the
six orange purchase.
I should be able to buy six
oranges with digital cash as
opposed to cash.
So if I'm going
into Pakistan, you
have a lot of hawkers,
people with the small trades.
If I'm doing a $1 purchase
and I'm paying in cash,
I should be able to
pay with digital cash.
And that acceptance
hasn't taken place.
That merchant acquisition
hasn't taking place yet.
And when it does,
suddenly you'll
see a very high level of
activity in mobile account.
And the third thing
was the five click
onboarding-- that if you
are sitting in a village
and you want to become
an e-commerce merchant,
you should be able
to, in five clicks,
be able to set up the
photograph of your product,
set up your payment mechanism,
set up your logistic mechanism.
And the fifth click you
should become a merchant.
Obviously, that needs
3G and 4G coverage,
which is happening in Pakistan.
So those things, when
you have those kinds
of things happening,
suddenly you
see digital transactions
taking place.
So that was the challenge, and
I think we're halfway there.
So we've got the
mobile accounts open.
Now we have to make them active.
SPEAKER 1: As a
startup investor,
what is your view on
the current technology
and entrepreneurial
scene in Pakistan?
NADEEM HUSSAIN: So
Pakistan, remember,
is a country of
200 million people.
You know, that's a lot of
European companies combined,
and you won't get to
200 million people.
The lens you see
Pakistan from here
is, there's blood
in the streets.
There's bomb blasts,
or the prime minister
has been removed for corruption.
Negative news carries easily.
And I've been here for
two days, and I've met,
I think, 12 people
already, a lot of them
VCs, just talking about
what's happening in Pakistan.
Because there's a
counter-narrative to what's run
by CNN and Fox--
you know, a lot of
positive things happening.
So what's happened in the last
six, seven years in Pakistan
is an emerging middle
class, for example.
There's 30 million people
in the emerging middle class
with purchasing power.
Because the inflation rate has
been around 4%, 4 and 1/2%,
salaries and the company growth
rate has been around 8% to 10%,
so people have been
getting incremental income.
And now you have
30 million people
in one country which
have purchasing power.
Right now, there are 45 million
smartphones in Pakistan,
which is expected to go
up to 80 million by 2020.
So remember the
smartphone is calling--
and you guys know
this better than me--
calling is just 1% of a
feature of a smartphone.
It's the biggest invention
I see that's happened
in our lifetime, and it's going
to revolutionize many things.
If you have a smartphone,
I can do e-health with you,
I can do e-education with
you, I can do e-entertainment
with you, I can do e-financial
services with you--
and I'll talk [INAUDIBLE]
of the initiatives here.
Basically, the world changes
when you have a smartphone.
By 2020, Pakistan is going
to get 90% GSMS coverage--
3G and 4G all over Pakistan.
So suddenly, rural Pakistan gets
connected with urban Pakistan.
And with purchasing
power increasing,
you've got a whole
bunch of people who
can now-- it works both ways.
They can buy things which they
previously didn't have access
to, or I have access to them.
I can run a remote
education program.
I can do e-health consultations
at clinics, whichever doctor
is present in Karachi, but I'm
in a remote part of Pakistan,
and I can do diagnostics.
And then I can use
e-payments to pay the fee,
immediately uplink, and
again, use my e-pharmacy
to send the medicines
out to those people.
So Pakistan is now
getting connected.
And this is what I'm talking
to the VCs over here, that
here is a country which is
starved for seed capital.
They have two PE firms
and three VCs in Pakistan.
I'm the largest Indian
investor in Pakistan.
And I'm far from
a high net worth,
as far as Pakistan's rich
families are concerned,
which are sitting on
half a billion of cash--
liquidity, half a
billion dollars, OK?
And if I am the largest
individual investor,
it's a travesty, because these
guys can invest a lot more.
But I view this as
a major opportunity
because I think Pakistan
is grossly undervalued.
With all these things
I'm talking about,
this big consumer is
going to take place,
and the valuations over
a period of time go up.
The VCs outside Pakistan will
recognize Pakistan as a country
where they ought
to come and invest
once they get over the
Pakistan risk hurdle.
And then what
valuations we have now
are going to
exponentially increase,
and people who
invest now are going
to be able to ride that benefit.
They're taking the
initial risk, and people
will get rewarded for being
in Pakistan at the right time.
SPEAKER 2: We have a
Livestream question.
The question is whether
the regulatory environment
in Pakistan poses a huge
challenge to the startups.
And what is changing,
and what can
the startups do to
not fall into that?
NADEEM HUSSAIN: So, you know,
there's good news and bad news.
The good news, for
example, if people
are starting a
microfinance institution,
Pakistan's regulatory
environment
is recognized by the
economic intervention unit,
as number three in the world,
so that's very sorted out.
But if you're not in
a microfinance world,
then it's a challenge,
because the laws
are geared for the old economy.
And they're not geared
for the new economy.
So if you look at
neighboring India,
they have startup India where
they have taken five or six
different things
and said, we've got
to change these laws if we are
going to make an entrepreneur
culture happen in India.
Pakistan's recognized
those things.
For example, if I want
to register my company,
I ought to be able
to do it online,
and painlessly, and there
should be a separate window.
That window exists, but it's
not very effective right now.
If I am investing, I
should be able to do
a down round, which Pakistan
law doesn't currently allow.
I should be able
to give employee
options, which Pakistan law
doesn't currently recognize.
So we've identified
all the issues
working with the Securities
and Exchange Commission,
working with the tax regime--
now to provide shelter for
both investor and investees,
because you're going to have
a lot of startups that fail.
And you want to make
that investor actually
get some protection
for all that money that
gets written off initially.
So getting there.
We're not there yet.
But it's recognized
by the government
now that Pakistan
has the largest youth
cohort in the world.
75% of people are under 35.
50% of people are under 25.
As these young people
graduate, there's
no way our current
economy can absorb them
through regular
employment, so there
has to be entrepreneurship.
In order to make that
entrepreneurship,
it can be a dividend,
or it can be a bond.
Because if you don't
have employment
for the youth coming
out, then they'll
get into what I
call reverse ATMs.
So when you stop at a
traffic light, they say,
can I have your phone?
Can I have your wallet?
Can I have anything
else that [INAUDIBLE]??
And they'll be withdrawing
from you non-voluntarily, OK?
[LAUGHTER]
Because you've got to
give them employment.
There has to be means for
them to sustain themselves.
So that's why the government in
the private sector, and that's
why I have so much passion
for entrepreneurship because I
think that's the future.
Because Pakistan is
such a young population,
and I work with young
people, and they
have far more brilliant ideas
than I can even think of.
And they need an
environment where
people can believe in them,
mentor them, help them grow,
and provide capital.
But I'm just one
person, so we need
to have a whole slew of
people and support system
from the government that
makes this a much, much bigger
play on a grander scale.
And we're getting there,
but we're not there yet.
SPEAKER 2: So follow-up question
on that note, what roles are
dedicated incubators playing?
And if you can name
a few, which are
playing active role in this?
NADEEM HUSSAIN: So there are
34 incubator accelerators
in Pakistan, and I would say
probably three years ago,
there were five.
So there's a mushrooming
and understanding
that incubators and
accelerators can play a role.
There's PlanX, Plan9, Nest
i/o, my incubator, 10XC.
You know, universities
are incubators as well.
It's good news and
bad news again.
The good news is
that entrepreneurs
who want to go into an
accelerator incubator program
now are able to get mentorships.
They are able to get
co-working space.
The bad news is there's
only one accelerator that
actually pays you or values
you and gives you money.
And once you graduate,
there's not enough seed funds
available over there, VCs,
that when you're graduating
and your initial capital is
burned up, to give you money.
So the risk we run
sometimes is that you
can have default
rates far higher
than the natural
95% default rate,
because there's not enough
capital once you graduate.
And that's one of
the things that I'm
spending at least the
bulk of my time on,
is getting people so that
seed funds and VCs are theirs,
so when people graduate and
have a great idea they don't
die because of lack of capital.
They ought to die
because it's an idea that
can be scaled, not because
there's no capital,
and great ideas just,
you know, finish off.
SPEAKER 1: OK, we have time
for maybe one last question.
SPEAKER 2: Do we have
questions from the audience?
NADEEM HUSSAIN: Mesmerized.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 2: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How long do you think
it would take for behaviors
to change as far as actually
using digital wallet
and digital transactions
on the six orange thing
that you were talking about?
NADEEM HUSSAIN: So one of the
constraints of the six orange--
if you know the
banking business,
then there's something
called merchant acquiring.
That if you use your
credit card or debit
card at a merchant or the point
of sale machine, POS machine,
where he just swipes your card.
And, you know, the
payment gets made.
It takes money from
your credit card
and pays it to the supplier.
So the constraint in Pakistan
was that that POS machine cost
about, let's say, $30, $35.
And if I want to go
to a real small shop,
his or her inventory is
not equal to the $30 risk
I'm taking.
Or if I want to build 100,000
merchants, I need $30 million
of capital to put 100,000
machines in place.
But technology has a
way of changing things,
and now you have QR codes.
So a QR code now
at a merchant can
be put in where a POS machine
is no longer required.
And if the customer
has a smartphone,
he just puts his QR code,
and a payment can be made.
But the challenge that's
still remaining is that--
typically, the way
that a bank makes
money is that there's something
called a Merchant Discount
Rate, MDR.
So if you sign
[? up a ?] merchant,
the merchant's going to
pay you 1 and 1/2%, 1%,
depending on where
you are in the world,
as fees for the facilitation
that you're doing
for increasing their sales.
Because other than
cash, a person
can come in and use a
credit card or a debit card.
But a mom-and-pop
store or a hawker
are not going to give you 1%.
He says, thank you very much.
I like cash.
First, you're asking
me not to take cash.
Then you want to charge
me for not taking cash?
Doesn't work for me.
So this business model
needs to be worked out
that if you create
these merchants
then you make money from float,
as opposed to transaction fee,
and the Pakistani
market is not there yet.
So while QR code has
been established,
and people like experimenting
like [INAUDIBLE] with QR
codes, or HBL, or Mastercard,
the real inflection point
has come when they figure
out the business model.
AUDIENCE: Do you think that's
a major hurdle right now?
NADEEM HUSSAIN: Yeah, but I
think we're about, probably,
a year to 18 months away
before that gets correct.
I'm going to take a shot at
it as well, so let's see.
Great.
SPEAKER 2: All right.
So we have one final
question-- maybe a minute
and a half for that
pretty broad one.
What can companies like Google
and other [INAUDIBLE] companies
do, in your opinion, in
the emerging markets?
NADEEM HUSSAIN: I think one
of the things Google or large
players can do, very
honestly, broad response--
believe in Pakistan, believe
in the talent that exists,
and use some of the CSR and
non-CSR money in supporting--
and some of that is
already being done.
So 10XC, my accelerator
has a special deal
for data with cloud funding
from Google for startups,
but there's going to
be a lot more of that.
Take some investment dollars.
Put it in the
infrastructure in Pakistan.
Because this is, like I said,
a 200 million people country
with a large youth
cohort, which will become
Google customers for life.
So there's a lot more investment
that needs to take place,
and a lot more understanding
and appreciation
of what the local dynamics
are, not just for Google,
but for other people
in the Bay Area who
want to access a country
of 200 million people.
SPEAKER 1: Let's
thank our speaker.
[APPLAUSE]
NADEEM HUSSAIN: Thank you.